i feel so free like i feel more
authentic to who i am
demi lovato is letting go and not
looking back when it comes to her
signature
long locks i feel more myself now back
in november the pop star debuted her
drastically different do
and on monday's ellen degeneres show
demi revealed why she made the change
i've talked a lot about my past being in
recovery from an eating disorder and i
used to use my hair
as like to hide behind you know and it
would cover my body
and so when i started doing all this
work on myself i thought what is
something that i've been holding on to
my whole life
that i need to let go of and it was that
up next for demi
she's unveiling more about herself in
her upcoming youtube documentary
demi lovato dancing with the devil like
what led to her 2018 overdose
and how she's learned from it i've
snatched
[Music]
what's
is she alive people are gasping her
oxygen levels are dangerously low i said
what do you mean she's gonna make it
you're watching
all of her blood come out of her body
into a machine
she was like i can't i can't see i can't
see anything
we live in a time where nobody's perfect
and we're not going to get role models
by
watching people not make mistakes we're
going to
meet and learn from our role models who
have
overcome their deepest darkest struggles
also in the documentary we'll see the
singer address her now former engagement
to actor
max eric i'm engaged i've really
struggled with this
the two split back in october but demi
did tell ellen about an
unconventional date she went on this
person had asked me on a date
have you ever been skydiving before and
i said
no but i've always wanted to and they
said we have to go sometime
didn't know the next date would be us
skydiving
and sure enough we we go and we jumped
from
the highest point that you can go
without an oxygen tank which is
14 000 feet or above we free fell for
two minutes and i couldn't say
no and although she didn't name any
names
she did reveal it was a seemingly
short-lived romance
is that relationship still going on
they're a friend they're a good friend
okay yeah but um but no but no